das ist der club the pearl gestern nacht
und dieser klub hatte eigentlich
angekündigt keine party zu veranstalten
diese halloween party abzusagen und hier
sieht man wie trotzdem gefeiert wurde
eine illegale halloween party dafür habe
ich kein verständnis und das hat auch
nichts mit halloween zu tun das wäre
auch in den letzten wochen schon falsch
und im übrigen auch nicht gestattet
gewesen
frau schwesig wenn sie diese bilder
sehen was geht ihnen da durch den kopf
ich finde es unverantwortlich gestern
konnten die kids nicht durch die straßen
ziehen
nirgendwo wurde geklingelt und die
kinder haben verzichtet und hier wird so
eine party gemacht dass der club
betreiber macht das geht schlichtweg
nicht und das was die gäste machen
da muss man unterscheiden da fehlt
offensichtlich noch am verständnis dafür
dass es eine zwingende notwendigkeit
gibt wenn wir uns vor infektionen
schützen wollen dass wir halt auf solche
partys jetzt wieder verzichten das ist
auch ein blick auf die gastronomen die
ab morgen schließen müssen die sich an
alles vorbildlich gehalten haben echt
unverhältnismäßig das geht eigentlich
gar nicht das ist so ungefähr als ob ich
mich betrinken und dann noch meine
kinder ins auto setzte und dann fröhlich
durch die gegend war das doch genau das
problem dass massen events und solche
partys in den letzten wochen und monaten
haben stattfinden können und die haben
das infektionsgeschehen dramatisch mit
verschlechtert deswegen ist es zwingend
notwendig dass politik darauf reagiert
indem sie weiter kommuniziert und den
menschen erklärt warum wir das tun und
warum wir es uns nicht leisten können
dass die infektionszahlen so steil
weiter nach oben gehen wie wir das in
den letzten tagen und wochen erlebt
haben ich habe dafür null verständnis
und ich finde dass es klare konsequenzen
haben muss